[Music]
when manga or anime become liveaction
movies things often go wrong but
exceptions prove the rule in 2019 Alita
battle Angel was able to convince both
viewers and critics the hit adaptation
by Robert Rodriguez and James Cameron
ended with a cliffhanger leaving fans
around the world asking when is Alita 2
coming there is no lack of story
material the first movie merely covers
the first two volumes of the nine-part
manga series in addition battle Angel
Alita other stories also offers an
alternative ending that can be taken
into consideration since there have been
frequent statements from the film team
about the Alita sequel lately we would
like to bring you up to date with this
video naturally for Alita battle Angel 2
it is logical to bring together those
responsible for the successful
predecessor producer John landow
recently told us that efforts are
already underway to get action Legend
Robert Rodriguez to take over his
director again but so far there's been
no final commitment another important
contributor to the project is Avatar
Creator James Cameron he was the main
driving force behind adapting the manga
into a film in the first place and
originally even planned on directing the
film in the end he passed this task on
to Rodriguez but he did write the script
for Alita battle Angel for example in an
interview with Forbes which was actually
about the sale of his mansion He
revealed some amazing details about the
franchise he is currently working in
Austin Texas on the next Alita battle
Angel movies yes movies plural so
apparently not only part two is in the
works but possibly also an Alita 3 and
More in view of the extensive story
that's actually not all that surprising
in an older interview Cameron disclosed
that more than 600 pages of notes were
written during the filming of part one
in addition to Rodriguez and Cameron two
other names are inseparably linked with
the film lead actress Rosa Salazar as
well as Kristoff Waltz both have already
expressed that they are excited to
return for the cast of Alita
2 in the fascinating world of battle
Angel Alita there are endless
possibilities for an exciting second
film taking the original mangas from the
the '90s and the first movie as a
starting point there are several
promising story lines for the
realization the previous film focused
mainly on the first two volumes of the
manga and part of the third volume which
deals with alita's quick rise in
motorball and the tragic loss of Hugo a
promising take on the second part is
alita's life as a hunter Warrior and her
attempts to come to terms with her grief
for Hugo her mysterious past also offers
plenty of potential for a deep dive
however the question of ZEM the floating
city in the sky looms over everything
what does it look like and who inhabits
it a fascinating aspect that was hinted
at in the first movie is the removal of
brains from some adults they are
controlled by microchips which gives
Nova control over their bodies it's
questionable how many of these zombies
there actually are in Iron City and what
role they will play so far Nova has been
presented to us as the main villain but
there's another character who has a
personal score to settle with Alita
zapan was badly injured by Alita in part
one and is obviously out for revenge for
this he will surely get Mighty support
from zalem in the manga there is an
exciting character that could make his
debut in Alita too namely chaos he
possesses psychometric abilities and can
learn about other people's pasts by
touching them he plays a major role in
uncovering alita's mysterious Warrior
past this would be an ideal way to tie
in with the manga prequel battle Angel
Alita Mars Chronicle not only do these
Works deal with the Great War but also
with life on Mars and Earth as well as
the conflicts between the two planets so
there is plenty of source material and
interesting possibilities for a second
film in the Elita battle Angel series we
strongly assume that James Cameron will
continue to strongly follow the original
manga but of course it remains exciting
to find out which aspects the focus will
be on and which details may be left out
with all these options there is still
the question of when Alita 2 will be
released well patience is still required
in this regard because regardless of how
far James Cameron has made progress on
the project as long as the writer strike
continues in the United States a
finished script is unlikely to be
available anytime soon long-term plans
for signing up the the crew and actors
are also doubtful at this point even if
everything goes well we don't anticipate
a theatrical release before 2025 or
2026 what do you guys think was part one
really as good as many say and what do
you expect from the sequels let us know
in the comments and if you liked our
little update about our Lita battle
Angel we would highly appreciate your
thumbs
[Music]
up